c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riches devaient mettre le petit
suisse la voilà il est le manger voyons
pas volé que j'essaye alors sachez
amputation ils sont ils sont variés donc
faites gaffe quand même les manger pas
complètement non mais c'est vrai il faut
taper où vous tapez l'aca barnetta put
sa garde à vue
ouais c'est ça attention vous allez le
faire après regardez vous avez fait un
pas vers moi tant des données à yahia
[Applaudissements]
attention à vous a bouleversé fréquences
émises à ben oui c'est pas du petit
suisse est 6eme lui connaît mais voulez
je vous le mets tu mets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me pose
vous voulez je vous la pose de petits
suisses il est pas c'est comparer c'est
vrai c'est parce que c'est du petit
suisse a varié on veut pas on veut pas
gâcher de la nourriture ouais c'est là
qu'il faut taper moi j'ai tapé l'amener
là alors fait un oui attention elles
devront faire moi aussi j'aime tension
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans les remplacer et je suis content
sauf qu'il est soit beau il est périmé
oui mais c'est rien c'est rien ne les
dépasse et riachy dégueulasse
[Musique]